basically the training has been rigorous
about five days a week two hours a day
put on about 20 pounds of muscle or what
I hope is muscle hope is muscle it feels
good to have that discipline because
Victor stone before he became cyborg was
a college athlete back in 1981 George
Paris and I created cyborg he was sort
of an outlier now he's the Vanguard he
is what we are becoming because as our
natural parts fade they're being
replaced by tech they're being placed by
computers inside of us Jeff Jones and he
was writing the Justice League and put
him in there and took him to the next
step and move more into the current time
period he understood that this is
character who lives in the Internet
in a way that he could see what's
happening all around the world steppin
all up there sorry it's bizarre Knopf in
northern Russia cyborg is always online
this epic backdrop is the digital
landscape and the digital landscape is
so important to us today it's such a
part of our world that our world would
not function the same without it and if
you have mastery over that digital
landscape you have ultimate power and
what do you do with that power we're all
cyborgs these days got a cell phone in
your pocket I've got a cell phone in my
pocket didn't you feel naked if you
don't have it we've come to a place
where we're so dependent on technology
we feel lonely so cyborg is the
amalgamation of those ideas is actually
the gateway to where I believe we may or
may not
we headed in the future with cyborg
it'll be interesting to see just how his
technology it can either help or hurt
the human race the possibilities are
endless thanks Alfred but I'll take it
from here do I know you
[Music]
you